bonjour à tous et merci de votre accueil
respirez aussi vous allez en avoir
besoin
d'ailleurs on va faire maintenant c'est
de prendre une bonne assise
j'avais décroiser les jambes mais sur
votre dossier
d'aller fermer les yeux vous allez faire
exactement ce que je vous dis on n'est
pas dans une secte je sais pas vous
respirez calmement il ya mon signal vous
prendrez une profonde inspiration
allez-y tenez écouter observer ressentez
ce qui se passe à l'intérieur de vous
votre corps dans votre esprit
et maintenant relâchés on était pas mal
est ce que vous avez pu ressentir
c'était plutôt quelque chose d'agréable
certaine plénitude un confort ils
maîtrisent vois ce que je ressens au
fond de l'eau c'est les sensations
décuplée fois cent fois mille je suis
champion du monde plonge adapté dans la
discipline du poids constant sans palmes
ça jette pour pallier à ce que ça veut
dire en fait heureusement j'ai pu voir
sur la vidéo que je suis censé
m'immerger le monde un câble qui sans
aucune assistance à l'est qui pourrait
entraîner une paire de palmes rien du
tout
le tract et à la corde pas du tout jeune
âge la brasse j'y vais une profondeur
déterminée elle avance que je sais où je
vais et gens décrochent le bac est
témoin qui symbolise ce qu aller
chercher les premiers hommes ya déjà
plusieurs milliers d'années quand il
s'immergeait et puis je remonte toujours
par mes propres manières jeune âge et
m'attends à une équipe de juges qui est
là pour valider ou non la performance en
fonction d'un certain nombre de critères
un protocole bien précis et ja la
profondeur si j'y suis allé et puis si
je maîtrise mon d'apnée si je ne tombe
pas par exemple en syncope gare de
connaissances mon activité basée sur la
maîtrise du souffle pour m'immerger dans
un milieu liquide
je suspends de souffle pour m'introduire
n'a filtré
m'engouffrer dans un autre monde
bien sûr le corps a besoin de cet apport
continu de ce comburant essentiel que
l'oxygène on ne sait ni pour notre
organisme
mais on peut vivre quelques instants
comme cela parce que d'une part notre
corps un certain nombre de réserves
certes limité mais aussi parce que il
peut fonctionner selon un processus
qu'il n'utilise pas d'oxygène pendant
quelques instants pendant quelques
minutes c'est le métabolisme année on y
reviendra tout à l'heure il y a un
certain nombre d'adaptations
effectivement quand on plonge et lorsque
je descends fond de l'eau je fus gêne un
peu avec cet élément et c'est comme si
le sens et le seul essence l'espace et
le temps se modifie j'ouvre une porte
sur une autre dimension mais qui n'est
pas simplement extérieur à moi bien sûr
l'univers marin on l'a vu tout à l'heure
avec un des précédents intervenants et
riche de millions d'espèces une
connaissons qu'à peine 10% ces 70% la
surface du globe
nous sommes issus aussi des océans aux
origines de la vie mais on parle aussi
d'un voyage intérieur dans ma discipline
on va quelque quelque part où il n'y a
rien que du bleu mon père me disait
quand j'étais petit et que je m'étais un
peu va voir là bas si j'y suis sur le
ton de l'humour
j'y suis allé je n'ai pas vu moi je ne
sais pas si je me suis vu mais tout ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que je vais
essayer de vous initier un petit peu ce
que ressent dans la plus profonde à
travers quatre notion la première c'est
l'humilité
regardez bien ces photos son contraste
ses couleurs ses formes
sa lumière la mer la mer est un univers
sauvage puissant attirant captivant mais
aussi
inquiétant angoissant austin
je vais à la mer dans un esprit humble
et apaisé respectueux et rempli de
simplicité
je ne vais pas à la mer dans un esprit
conquérant combattants la mer est
toujours plus forte
une annonce que jamais alors cette
humilité n'empêche pas la fierté que
j'ai mon parcours de mes résultats issus
d'un travail de longue haleine de
plusieurs années rien n'a été rien est
inné chez moi c'est que du travail
autodidacte je n'ai pas d'entraîneur
mais lorsque je suis au fond de l'eau
que ça soit en situation d'entraînement
de compétition parce que j'aime me
balader aussi je randonne comme certains
le font dans les halles je suis je n'ai
pas cette sensation d'invincibilité est
plutôt une notion de comment dire
privilège d'être là où je suis et ce
côté éphémère parce que je descends mais
je dois remonter je ne suis pas un
poisson pour respirer renforce ce
sentiment unique deuxième notion
d'adaptation arrêté sa respiration pour
s'immerger dans un milieu hyperbare à
haute pression entraîne un certain
nombre d'adaptations de modifications
physiologiques et cela pour tout le
monde mais pour vous dès la première
appli est en plus l'entraînement
potentialise ses effets c'est à dire
qu'un analyste expert va réagir
davantage qu'un sujet débutants ces
adaptations les voici
la première la plus connue c'est une
bradycardie une chute du rythme
cardiaque
le corps se met au ralenti pour
fonctionner en économie et la perception
également semer au ralenti autre
phénomène une vasoconstriction du
système artérielle périphérique dans les
membres inférieurs
les membres supérieurs mais aussi les
organes la digestion qui ne sont pas
essentiels à cet instant de survie
milieux extrêmes on profite d'une
vasodilatation centrale pour le coeur et
le cerveau qui sont les deux organes
nobles essentiel à notre survie de ce
moment et qui supporte mal hypoxie le
manque d'oxygène
autre phénomène des transferts sanguin
assez important déjà initié par la
vasoconstriction puisqu'il faut bien
chasser cette masse sanguine qui est
dans ses membres dans ses organes
elle a tendance naturellement à venir
dans le compartiment central
et puis lorsque vous descendez vous
allez aussi dans un milieu hyperbare
ajout me dit tout à l'heure on augmente
un bar de pression tous les dix mètres
lorsque je suis à 100 mètres de
profondeur g11 bars de pression
supplémentaire sur le corps alors je
pars avec un certain volume pulmonaire
je suis en surpression et puis je
descends ces pressions appui mon volume
diminue et il se crée un certain vide
relatif
un phénomène d'aspiration qui pourrait
être le très néfaste pour nous alvéoles
alors il se crée un phénomène passif
d'afflux sanguin qui va remplir la veine
cave l'aorte le système artérielle
pulmonaire pour combler ce vide et
protégez nous avait une autre adaptation
la contraction de la rate
cet organe qui est le siège des cellules
militaires mais aussi des globules
rouges en fin de nuit et dès la première
année vous avez une contraction de cet
organe qui va re libérer un certain
nombre de globules circulant pour capter
davantage d'oxygène et le donner au
coeur et au cerveau je mets dit tout à
l'heure
parallèlement à cela l'organisme se met
en économie d'oxygène il va essayer de
tendre en moins à moins consommer pour
le garder pour le bénéfice du coeur et
du cerveau
autre adaptation corporelle cette fois
ci nous avons une augmentation de la
capacité pulmonaire total j'ai pour ma
part presque 11 litres dans les poumons
alors qu'un sujet lambda sédentaires
aurait entre 4 et 5 litres je suis
habitué aussi à supporter des taux
d'oxygène très bas dans mon corps était
taux de dioxyde de carbone très très
importants dus aux échanges et à
cependant l'appui et puis bien sûr je ne
prends pas de p o mais la cne en force
le taux d'hématocrite et taux
d'hémoglobine c'est aussi une adaptation
sanguine à cette activité pour pouvoir
comme je lis tout à l'heure irrigué et a
provisionné ces deux organes essentiels
à notre survie et puis vous avez
également une adaptation thoracique les
immersions répéter entraîne des
compression de la cage thoracique plus
des étirements spécifique à sec font que
nous sommes adaptés à nous immerger de
manière très profond ainsi lorsque nous
nous immergeons nous sommes en fait
adapté façonné à l'environnement liquide
nous devenons un peu des mammifères
marins ou presque des mets rien
c'est une notion qui avait développé
jacques rougerie c'est le march é taient
kt et océanographe qui parlait en fait
tu peuple humain qui serait capable de
s'approprier n'ont pas de dompter mais
de d'évoluer en totale harmonie avec un
autre monde
le milieu liquide qui deviendra un autre
espace vital
autre notion le détachement si on résume
de manière assez brut mon activité poids
constant sans palmes et c'est de manière
très terre à terre
je m'immerge dans un milieu liquide qui
n'est pas le mien sans insistance même
pas une paire de palmes il fait plus
froid plus sombre d'une vision
hypermétropes c'est à dire que je vais
avoir je dois avoir un masque pour voir
quelque chose et comme il ya rien je
n'en ai pas je suis seul et puis je suis
en apnée je respire pas ça donne pas
vraiment envie d'y aller rajoutez à cela
un contexte compétitif
je fais une annonce il ya un juge il ya
un classement
ça fait beaucoup et puis l'univers marin
aussi fantastique soit il sait aussi
toutes les projections fantasmagorique
de l'homme depuis des millénaires
c'est l'évocation d'un vestiaire réel
imaginaire des monstres fantastiques une
notion d'engloutissement qui sont
clairement à rapprocher à une symbolique
de mort mais aussi de renaissance de
passage vers un autre monde vers autre
chose une immensité profonde et puis
l'univers marin se sont essayés et mité
la mythologie l'évocation de naf de
naïade de dieu les projections de désir
d'éternité
j'en passe j'aime bien utiliser cette
notion de détachement mais comme henri
bergson utilise alors j'ai un petit peu
vous montrez ce en quoi consiste alors
bien sûr eu un détachement c'est une une
mise à distance vis-à-vis quart par
rapport à une situation immédiate prise
de distance affective et émotionnelle et
b reçoit le définit aussi de cette
manière c'est à dire une merde
une manière de percevoir les choses sans
passer par le biais du sens des mots du
langage les étiquettes collées sur elle
et donc c'est un détachement naturel
avec une manière quasi virginale
originel devoir penser sentir et donc
ici de ressentir au plus profond
sans forcément passer par la
quantification du langage dernières ne
sont que partagent mon compagnon qui est
ici et qui m'accompagne sur les derniers
instants avant une immersion meute ya
juste les pieds il ne dit rien mais par
ce simple geste il me permet d'être bien
droit dans l'eau allongé calme apaisé
reposer ce qui me permet de le ventiler
calmement sereinement avant de basculer
de l'autre côté du miroir
l'apnée est un sport individuel
pratiques et collectivement une
existants que par le groupe
c'est une activité à risque mais nous
l'analysons maximum grâce au groupe
nous descendons le long d'un câble nous
sommes plongés à celui ci nous allons
une profondeur déterminé à l'avance et
puis ce câble est relié à un contrepoids
qui est gérée par une personne en
surface qui pourrait être capable de
remonter de manière très rapide il ya un
sondeur qui nous suit en temps réel qui
nous dit si vous êtes en train de
descendre de remonter si vous êtes en
face de statique et puis on l'a vu tout
à l'heure il ya aussi les apnéistes de
sécurité qui sont là pour vous
accompagner jusqu'à parfois 40 mètres de
profondeur seront derniers instants lors
de votre montée puisque c'est là
qu'arrive éventuellement des pertes de
connaissance dans les compétitions
internationales ce sont de véritables
athlètes entraîné des équipes formées
pour ça nous à l'entraînement on n'a pas
toutes ces personnes à disposition on a
malgré tout ce matériel mais nous jouant
tour à tour les différents rôles celui
d'acteur principal
et puis celui d'ange gardien qui va
permettre à l'acteur de s'exprimer
les apnéistes ne sont pas des illuminés
suicidaire qui pond seuls dans leur coin
n'existons que grâce et par un groupe
avec lequel nous partageons nos valeurs
j'espère vous avoir initié interpellé
sur ce qui est la plus profonde la plus
profonde
certes en terme de performance mais la
planète ouvert à tous je vous invite à
vous immerger dans l'eau ça a un effet
bénéfique sur le corps énorme ça libère
les tensions s'apaisent ça permet de se
recentrer sur soi de s'écouter
dans un monde où aujourd'hui tout le
monde court et puis si vous avez
l'occasion de le faire dans le grand
bleu c'est encore mieux
l'univers est fantastique et s'avoue
vert permettra peut-être vous aussi
d'ouvrir une porte sur une autre
dimension
merci de votre attention